but what else is what else is happening
your life but you gotta works just life
dude you know man just live in life
alone
yeah quarter mile at a time what do you
mean back quarter mile one quarter mile
time bro like Vin Diesel like Vin Diesel
I don't know what that means either
he lose his life one core amount of time
right okay so in other words you drag
race
I don't drag race it I don't like I like
to race though you like to race what why
am I gonna what do you like Friday 458
or 488 which one do you provide didn't
say anything about Ferrari I thought you
did I didn't say a damn thing about for
is I forsaken I thought you're like are
you gonna buy it for Roy because I'm I I
didn't I don't know why jeez do you like
blue in spa wait a minute I'm just
browsing um you don't brown when you
brow I live my life 1/4 mile at a time
when you I know what happens now you
give Rogan a call and you say can I do
this and he goes do it and you like put
it super expensive and he goes shut up
don't be a [ __ ] correct that's he said
to me correct and I didn't listen to him
but you're gonna listen to him are you
getting a Ferrari
maybe dude it's either 48 or 458 what's
the difference well I'm so glad yes once
a v8 naturally aspirated and then ones
event Sandstrom in turbo I think the
older ones that's right though well
better gas mileage however right they're
both the same as far as speed goes right
so you want to go better gas mileage mm
I like naturally aspirated myself why
turbos and stuff like that
one at 660 horsepower one has five six
you get to the same speed the 48 the new
one 48 replaced the 450 I was a 48 the
v6 with the twin with the 458 the v8 the
488 s-- the new one okay so they're they
look almost identical the exhaust is a
little different the engines completely
different yeah there it is FRA 458 verse
488 we can get a new one bro I don't buy
a new I buy used always why is that it
doesn't me as soon as you drive off the
lot you're down like 60 K 60 K always
also you can't go into the fryer
by a 48 GTV you can't know I think it's
my tattoo three-year waiting list
what why porque way it goes bro the man
and a lot then sometimes like if you
want like the fours or something like
that you can't like let's say you're a
billionaire you can't go in there violet
you have to be on the list you can't pop
yeah like you and there's certain
porches you just can't walk in and buy
you have to be like really yeah so so
are they made as far as still made in
the same factory or is it owned by some
nope same factory so it's not owned by
Ford or something
I forget who owns um but there's the 48
look at that [ __ ] thing that's a hell
of a car I have to admit I'm not a car
guy but that looks like a piece of
jewelry it looks like a piece of art I
don't think you can get that I like red
but I feel like white or black might be
the way yeah right it's like I calm down
I agree Lee I I come down understand it
but let me ask you this well it seems
very low to the ground don't you [ __ ] it
up all the time don't you have them look
at my gt3 RS is super well what I like
about you is you drive your you get
you'll buy a high-performance car guys
would keep it in and it becomes your
primary car yeah I don't look at am I
like I love to drive them I like a lot
of cars I just I don't know man
I told Rogan like a we're at the Comedy
Store the other night and he pulled up
in his new Land Cruiser which is amazing
it's a zombie apocalypse mobile that he
had custom-made it's ridiculous so I was
like dude I'm looking at a 450 and a 488
I know what do you think it's gonna stop
us it won't
it never well you're always gonna be
like this who's on the same way again I
thought when I get the RS I'd be fine no
you know you love cars love them
absolutely love em that's why people
have a ton of them but um it's it's a
pretty well if you're not into cars
though people I do what are you doing
I'm sure I like that Land Cruiser he has
those are sick but like Mikey Garcia on
food truck Diaries and he act like he
races cars he does yeah like straight-up
races Wow yeah that's it chin the white
and black bro that's what I'm diggin
right now I love with red interior
what's a hell of a car dude yeah it's
coming to that car at all you shouldn't
be man why be mad at that car just feel
like Reds a little much all right calm
down dude I think great greater black is
the way to go in the car
that's a hell of a car I feel like it's
so low you're gonna hit things all the
time my Porsche is lower really yes
but Porsche and Frey have buttons but
when you go up the curbs that lifts it
what's faster that car the Porsche whoa
well he just made a race car noise on
track why's that my Porsche destroys
that thing really my Jay Saab will talk
[ __ ] all day about Ferraris there you go
the Porsche gt3 RS the gt2 RS destroy a
thing on the track or how about I was
like eh I'm I'm talking about pulling
the trigger on this 458 said to be a
video of a McLaren just dusting and like
all right well well I'm not racing like
I'm not buying it because of the
quarter-mile time you go but you are
like no I'm not I'm literally Jason so
you're about this more in a car than you
are right now way more way more I'll
tell everything about my car this car
really yeah he's going to he's details
for this nautical my dad tries to calm
out
well my dad says he has some option on
his car but Jay knows cars so well he
just destroys it I don't know why that
brings me joy I might get a SAS I think
releasing your pit bull
yeah mailman yeah I don't know why why
do we like that but but Jason Porsche
guy Porsche Porsche McLaren but Porsche
like knows them better than clarin loves
McLaren those are just as expensive I
mean [ __ ] I mean the 488 the McLaren 5/7
interesting about your pores that you'll
sell your portion our trade it in and
you'll get you'll get a lot of money for
it right I mean do you think I'm not
gonna because you know what I'm saying
yeah you're not gonna lose money you're
almost in a way you're driving it for a
lot cheaper than people think cuz you
see your money back good you know I mean
now now let me get me a clearance don't
look as good now let me ask you this now
performance wise that thing was [ __ ] I'm
like I told you how much I spent on
horses for my lovely my lovely wife and
my daughter and I think you did I told
you a kid buy a Ferrari I told you that
whatever you said pick one pick a car
pick any car you want picking out if you
get the superfast one but there's one
for I call this price superfast
how much horses I mean we're talking me
an estimate 3,500 sure I don't
five I don't know how much a restful
everything I don't even know how much
either way 35 you do it there's the soup
I saw one I thought it looked like a
Corvette how do you mean a Corvette
that's I guess oh yeah you mean a
Corvette looks like that sir the fat I
don't like that car that's - I don't
like that small - light in the ass that
thing's bigger than I need an ass on my
car to lighten the ass there is no ass I
need an ass on my car Bob I can't have
that - light in the ass that's a short
somebody law he lost his ass NASA tall
mm-hmm
I mean come on I'd cut off one wife
toaster like really oh yeah
super fast a box you profess how fast is
it it's super fast it says in the title
dude yeah dad Tesla you like that you
like the the 488 and the 450 been in
that huh yeah much better much better
what about you chin I don't like sports
cars really well I like my credit 80
grand a Freddie take it easy
hold on Brandon come on take it easy let
me out let me handle this hold on sit
down let me handle this
Lenny he's probably just [ __ ] with
you relax hold on hold on
chin yeah Ken yes what are you dry right
now
2015 Toyota Prius good now Joan Bennett
it's white chin I'm gonna get chin I'm
gonna give you 200 grand
go you can have any car you want what is
it 200 grand
um a Bentley now you bet a truck I mean
a fancy Raptor like that that you want
to look Malloy in a truck but you don't
you want that post Malone Raptor the
six-wheeler luxury cars what